well if you caught the season premiere
of swat on cbs tonight you probably saw
images that were
pretty familiar the rodney king riots in
1992 sparked a racial reckoning in los
angeles
as well as here in las vegas and it's a
conversation that is especially
timely this year oracle mana explores
what's changed and the work that's left
to do
in late april 1992 riots erupted in los
angeles after four white
lapd officers were acquitted in the
beating of rodney
king the verdict leading to lootings
fires and violence in the streets
tensions also mounting in las vegas that
month a whole shopping center burned to
the ground
police cracking down on the
demonstrations i mean the city kind of
was on lockdown
unlv african-american studies professor
tyler perry says the protests in las
vegas were contained to the west side
a historically black neighborhood but
the unrest there did not happen
overnight
it wasn't just the rodney king verdict
that was kind of the
catalyst for what occurred this had been
bubbling up since the 1980s
particularly as you have a more
heavy-handed form of policing being
employed
when things settled down efforts were
made to bridge the gap between those
here on the west side
and the police and things improved
fast forward to 2020 when protesters
took to the las vegas strip following
the death of george floyd in minneapolis
police responding with improved policies
but still deploying the swat
team is that something that is
considered
a typical tactic yeah
unfortunately so somebody please man i
can't breathe
the recent protests and police response
as well as the rodney king riots in l.a
are explored in cbs's prime time drama
swat
the main character a black man in law
enforcement it was really bad you know
during those times
security expert jonathan simon is a
retired metro police sergeant and knows
that duality all too well
he worked security at nellis air force
base during the rodney king riots
as a african-american that's in law
enforcement
i believe the challenge in 1992
the challenge today is
we have to explain to our
kids that every police officer
is not that how do you you get that that
story
line straight the conversation is far
from over
and experts say collaboration is key
police perhaps
work toward gaining the trust of the
community coming together to address
racial
injustice in vegas and beyond orco mana
8 news now